[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time we're
doing another book review
so this is an author that i have covered
before i think a while back probably
last year a few months ago or something
like that i reviewed a book called no
one gets out alive which was actually
made into a movie for netflix which i
still haven't seen yet goddammit i
really need to get around to doing that
because i really really did um like that
book i think i first saw it
recommended on uh the jordaline reads
youtube page i really like her and her
recommendations are usually really good
and she really dug that book um and i
ended up really liking it uh myself and
then i noticed that uh recently this
book that had come out which is called
cunning folk also by adam neville now
billed as adam lg neville which i don't
think it was on the other book i'd have
to check i have it over there so please
but i saw this one turned up on my
kindle unlimited uh for free
so i said what the hell i like i really
liked his other books so let's check
this one out and uh also i was um really
tempted by it because it's folk horror
and i tend to really like those kind of
books and i will say that i think i
as much as i loved no one gets out alive
i think i liked this one a little bit
better just because i don't know i think
it was i think the story was a lot more
contained and a lot more intimate and a
lot of the imagery was a lot more
horrific
and i really like i said i really like
folk or folk horror elements and stories
there's not really a lot you know
there's not as much of that maybe as
there are some other kind of like ghost
stories and things like that so i really
did like this sort of uh kind of
original take on it now this book
actually is fairly recent uh just came
out in mid-september 2021 i believe uh
but yeah so if you have kindle unlimited
you can read this one for free and it is
definitely worth reading if you're into
folk or
and if you're into
the sub sub genre which
adam neville actually wrote kind of an
afterword for this book which is
actually pretty interesting and he's
saying that uh this is a neighbor horror
he's like well you don't really read
much about that and he was kind of going
and maybe extrapolating as to why that
was or or why there wasn't any uh but
yeah this is actually kind of like
a neighbor horror as well as a folk
horror
he also said uh another interesting
thing in the uh afterward that he wrote
was that
this book actually started out as a
screenplay
and that he had ended up writing a whole
bunch of different versions of this as a
screenplay
and because it still hasn't gone into
production he decided well [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna turn it into a novel and then
that way if it eventually gets made into
a movie cool if it doesn't then at least
you know the story didn't get a waste uh
because you know he's still he's he said
it's weird because even though he wrote
a whole bunch of different treatments of
this story as a screenplay he's like it
still took him more than a year and like
seven or eight different drafts like for
it to
go into a novel he's like because you
would think that it would be easier like
that because you already had everything
outlined out and stuff but it's totally
not because it's like a completely
different it's a completely different
format and i can see where he's going
with that because i would i was kind of
thinking the same thing i'm like i
wonder if it would be easier because
i've never really done that before i've
written like original screenplays and
original stories but i've never tried to
do one into the other so i don't know
how easy that would be apparently not
very easy at least according to him
so what do we have in this book now uh
adam neville is a british writer
and uh mostly grew up in england and i
believe in new zealand also so this book
is set in
rural england in in sort of like an
unspecified village he said it's in the
southwest of england somewhere but he
doesn't really go any farther than that
it's mostly just based around two houses
uh two kind of farm houses that are
right next to each other and like i said
it's kind of like a neighborhood it
doesn't really
go farther afield than that there's
really only one other house or one other
character that kind of plays into it to
any great degree so as i said this is a
very contained story just basically
being around these two houses
what you have at the beginning though is
there's like a a little bit of a
prologue rather where
a guy who is working on this
you know sort of falling apart rural
farmhouse
and he suddenly feels compelled to
essentially
hang himself you kind of have
the feeling that he's fixed up like a
few rooms of this house and like he
doesn't want to do this but it's almost
kind of like he can't stop himself
so
at this point you're kind of wondering
like is the house making him do it or
something like that because it's left
kind of like very vague so this guy
actually commits suicide in there
although like i said he seems like he
wasn't really
a willing suicide it was kind of like
the house or something else was forcing
him to
so we jump ahead six months
and there's this young family uh the dad
tom who is a graphic designer but uh has
been out of work he's been freelancing
but has recently lost a lot of his
clients or has lost his job
uh he has a wife named fiona who works
in a bank and they have a four-year-old
daughter named gracie
now they had lived in the city whatever
city it was in kind of this cramped like
two-bedroom apartment
and tom has got it into his head that
he's like well i want my little girl to
grow up in nature like you know so she
can run around in the yard and you know
just have like a more natural upbringing
instead of being like crammed into this
little bitty apartment with her parents
and so he just wants something better
for his family he wants this kind of
like rural life
so it seems from the implication at the
beginning that he has kind of picked out
this house i don't think that fiona his
wife was kind of like averse to it
necessarily but i think she's a little
more ambivalent about the whole
situation and she's just kind of going
along with it she's like yeah that might
be like a nice dream and everything i
think she has gone to see the house but
uh maybe didn't look at it as much as
maybe they should have
so they get this house which it will be
no surprise to anyone that uh this is
the same house that the guy committed
suicide in earlier
now they do know about this so they're
kind of saying hey you know we got all
we got 20 000 pounds like not knocked
off the price so we can't complain about
it too much but
it's still kind of in rough shape and
then when they show up like after
they've actually purchased it it seems
to be in like rougher shape than they
remembered when they were like actually
looking at it or getting the inspections
or whatever
and when they first go in the house tom
finds that he's really still kind of
creeped out by the fact that that guy
hung himself in there and he can't
really stop thinking about it one weird
thing though other than well there's a
lot of weird things like i said the
house seems like in shittier shape uh
the yard looks real ratty which like i
said that's not surprising since no
one's lived there for a long time you
know they said the last person that
lived there obviously killed themselves
they didn't get a lot of work done on it
and prior to that no one had really
stayed all that long you're thinking
this is going in sort of a haunted house
direction but that's not exactly what
this story is which like i said i think
it was cool because it was like a little
bit of a of an original take
uh they do notice there's this uh
caravan or as we would say in the united
states kind of like a little trailer or
something like a little rv type
situation
and uh it's kind of like this little
ratty thing and it's sort of like parked
in their driveway or across their
driveway and they're kind of like okay
now they only have one house that's next
door to them their neighbors
and weirdly even though their house kind
of looks all ratty and [ __ ] up
and abandoned the house next door is
like this beautiful like fairy tale
looking like everything is immaculate
and especially like the house looks
awesome but also the gardens are awesome
it's like these fabulous like lush
gardens and all these beautiful like
brightly colored flowers and it just
looks perfect so like the lawn like
looks like a golf course and it just
looks like
unbelievably amazing just like out of a
fairy story
so they're just kind of like and they're
like well you know the the contrast
between the way that property looks and
the way their property looks is
obviously making their property look a
lot worse by a comparison
so uh tom is just kind of like when he
gets he's like okay well i know this
looks bad right now
and i know that we just
put the down payment on the house and
now we have a mortgage and then i lost
my job
but he's trying to kind of like rally
his family to the point where uh you
know he's like well we have some savings
and it's like i won't be working so i'll
have all this time to fix the house up
and it's gonna be our forever home and
it's gonna be awesome and our daughter
gracie uh and also they have a little
dog named archie that they bought for
their daughter they're like it's gonna
be like the perfect family it's gonna be
rural she's gonna play in the woods and
the dog's gonna run around and it's
gonna be like a dream come true
so he says i'm gonna start working on it
immediately like right away problem
being though
that the people
that live in this picture-perfect house
next door i'd never really got a sense
of how close together these houses were
because it did seem like there was a
garden
between them
but a couple of scenes too i almost it
almost kind of sounded like they shared
a wall i don't think they shared a wall
like i don't think they were detached
this is england and i know that they
have detached and semi-detached and all
that other kind of stuff but i never got
the feeling that these houses were
attached to one another i thought they
were separate but there were a couple of
scenes in there where i kind of
questioned that for a second because he
seemed to say like oh he was banging on
the wall and the other people were
banging the wall and i'm like well if
there was a yard between you wouldn't
really hear that but i don't know it was
like a little bit confusing but anyway
uh so yeah so i'm not sure how far away
this other house is because it seemed
like there was a fence in like a line of
trees
uh you know because that kind of factors
in the plot later on
so the people that live next door are
the moots
that's their last name is moot
uh they actually don't find out what the
names are until later but it's like an
old guy whose name is magi moot and the
woman's name which you actually don't
find out until much later in the book is
actually medea now at first you think
these two are husband and wife they're
very very old and they're very very
weird and very very eccentric it's very
funny like the descriptions of them they
just look like these ridiculous
they just look ridiculous they're like
the old guy has kind of like the white
hair but it's like like a clown i kind
of pictured him looking sort of like
like goofy riffraff or something like
that and they said he's always wearing
these ridiculous things like these
bright yellow pants and all this other
kind of stuff like trousers not pants
because i know in the uk like pants or
underwear i get it you know trousers
yellow trousers she's wearing those and
then like the little woman who's like
this tiny little thin woman has this
like really weird like bowl cut hair
that's red and he's just talking about
like how clownish they look
they're also super
really really rude and like really
really condescending and basically they
seem to
ma they have no compunction about like
really making the family that just moved
in next door
uh feel very very unwelcome basically
without really coming out and saying it
at least at first uh the moots are
basically like we don't want you here
like every kind of thing that they do
and say like it you know exudes that
attitude
so
so these two horrible people which are
next door like i said they make these
condescending like passive aggressive
kind of statements and [ __ ] like that
and you know at first the family are
just kind of like trying to be friendly
but then they're like okay whatever you
weird old people it's like maybe they'll
be dead soon
you know what i'm saying uh so they're
trying like not to worry too much about
it like i said they're having some money
problems uh because the husband's lost
his job but fiona still has her job so
she basically has a week off you know
while they move and then she has to go
back to work and take the little girl to
school and tom is left uh in the house
by himself and he's kind of left with
this big task of trying to fix the place
up you know with their dwindling
finances and he's really trying to make
this
like i said a perfect home
for his uh burgeoning little family
but uh as you might imagine this is a
horror novel
and uh the [ __ ] with the neighbors the
moots starts to escalate precipitously
there's kind of a thing where gracie the
little girl she wants to kind of go play
in the woods behind the house
and she finds kind of like this magical
looking
clearing and like there's all this cool
[ __ ] back there like a mound and then
like the dog starts digging up like
these weird little
tiles that have like these kind of
strange symbols on them and [ __ ] like
that
and uh it turns out too that the moots
do not want any of them going into the
woods even though they don't own the
woods like it's not pri part of their
property it's actually um kind of public
property because it's like right behind
both of their back gates
so there's that and then um it starts to
kind of escalate even more when the
neighbors the moots like actually start
doing things that
are probably them like knocking the
fence over because they're saying oh
well it's like an old fence and you need
to tear that out because it looks shitty
and tom's like well yeah that's not
super high priority right now i still
have to like fix the inside of the house
i've only just finished my daughter's
room and now i have to do the bedroom
and i have to do all this other stuff
but they're like yeah well you need to
get on that and then it mysteriously
falls over you know in a way that made
it seem like it could have been an
accident because it was kind of like in
bad condition and then like other like
worse things start happening that again
uh are probably them but
they still have like plausible
deniability about it even though they
seem
they they're they're just these horrible
horrible people that seem like
they they almost kind of like come out
and gloat about it too
but the frustrating thing is that tom
the husband he's kind of home by himself
working on the house all day so he's the
one that's dealing with these
[ __ ] nuts like next door
and
so his wife doesn't really see it the
daughter doesn't really see it now the
daughter has been having some weird like
she's having some weird dreams and when
she goes back in the woods she thinks
she hears like a woman calling to her
which actually does kind of come into
play later on but you know that can be
explained away because that's just a kid
or whatever but
tom is becoming convinced that the moots
next door
are specifically have it out for them
and are kind of like
doing things to ruin their whole family
and it gets kind of you know as i said
it's folk horror so it does get kind of
like
magical as the time goes on like black
magic type situation but of course uh
you know tom is kind of the only one
that sees this and fiona doesn't really
believe him she just thinks that the
neighbors are [ __ ] and that he
should just ignore them and
he can't really do that because he
starts to become more and more convinced
that his family is actually in danger
from them and that they're gonna do some
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and that maybe you
know it takes him a while to get to this
point but that maybe they're using like
some supernatural means to
get them to leave or to like just subdue
some really [ __ ] up [ __ ]
to his family but again like
no one really believes him and it gets
to a point where he maybe starts to not
believe himself like maybe he's just
being paranoid maybe he's just having
like a run of bad luck and it's not them
at all and so there's that kind of like
tension going on with it as well uh so
yeah it just mounts up and mounts up and
this was one of those books that
i kind of feel like his other one like
no one gets out alive was like this too
but it's just one of those horror novels
that you just like read it and it starts
out kind of like oh that's [ __ ] up and
then oh man that's really [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] that is like super [ __ ] up but
it's just like getting worse and worse
and worse and it's just kind of like it
gets to a point too where you're just
kind of like i don't know how it's like
how are they gonna fix this kind of
thing because it's just getting so bad
and
it's just getting so uh catastrophic
that you're just like really not sure
how it's gonna resolve and it does and
actually i really liked the way that
this ended i liked the resolution of it
um because i really didn't know
how like i said i didn't know how it was
gonna get fixed because it just by the
time that it got to the end it was just
so
bad and so like out of his control that
i wasn't really sure how it was going to
go but i really did like how it went um
one criticism i did see i don't
necessarily have this but i see where
people are coming from the main
criticism i saw of this which was fairly
minor like most people seem to really
really like this and i really liked it
as well but the first part of the book
is very very descriptive and very like
densely descriptive i mean not to a
point where it's just like a slog or
anything but it does go a lot into
kind of describing
what this setting looks like like these
two houses um you know what the moot's
beautiful fairy tale lawn looks like
like all the flowers and stuff and like
what their
and then what uh tom and fiona's
property looks like which is kind of
like you know kind of broken down or
whatever and then kind of like
describing things in the woods so there
is a lot of like really
you know beautiful like descriptive
language
but i think some people thought that
that was like a little bit too much to
get through like i said i didn't really
feel that but i see where they're coming
from because there were there were some
kind of passages that i had to read them
a couple times because while they're
beautifully written and while they're
very evocative sometimes you really kind
of have to read them again like to get
the full impact of like what he's saying
or what he's describing so there is that
but
once uh it gets to kind of a tipping
point because like i said up to one
point it's just like these neighbors are
just [ __ ] right and it's just
like little [ __ ] like i said like oh did
they knock the fence over did they do
this that the other you know what i mean
did they park the caravan at the end of
the driveway and then there's like then
people will show up at their house and
there's like all kind of weird [ __ ]
going on like
like people be like kissing their hands
and all this other stuff so and tom's
watching being like what the [ __ ] like
who are these people so there's that but
it's just like little things at first
and then just gets worse and worse and
worse and worse until it's just like
[ __ ] crazy out there and so it really
gets to a point where
i mean toward the end it gets like
really gruesome and grisly and just kind
of like way the [ __ ]
elder gods type situation you know what
i mean so that kind of stuff is very
kind of uh evocative and descriptive as
well because there are scenes of it
where kind of where the magic the folk
magic stuff kind of takes hold where
it's almost like
i don't want to say lovecraftian but
it's kind of like you know
interdimensional
type of stuff or like i said you know
somebody's old gods in the earth and all
that kind of stuff so there is that
aspect to it as well overall i mean it
this really
i don't know this this one really kind
of like uh
got under my skin i think i really do
like folk horror
and
i just the way that this was written
like the way i could just kind of like
see it in my head and almost like a
fairy tale and like i said maybe it's
just because it started as a screenplay
and now i'm like now i'm dying to see
this as a movie i hope they make it into
a movie one day maybe they will because
they did make no one gets out alive i
think like a couple years ago was a
couple years ago it wasn't that long ago
but they made it to a movie for netflix
so i kind of i would actually really
like to see this as a movie because i
think this would i mean visually
just the descriptions of the woods and
the descriptions of the properties and
stuff like that would visually make a
great story and then like just as it
gets more and more horrific there was
all kind of like
gruesome like graphic [ __ ] that happens
like toward the end and kind of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that happens to
you know some uh
innocent characters uh that's pretty
terrible so there's that as well but
yeah i really really got into this and
uh like i said as good as no one gets
out alive is i think i actually liked
this one a bit better because i did like
the folk horror aspect and i did like
the neighbors from hell aspect which
like i said they don't he kind of went
into this a little bit in his um
in his afterward where he was saying
he's like i don't know why there's not
more
horror stories about terrible neighbors
he's like because of all the places i've
lived and he like kind of went on this
litany of like all these horrible
neighbors that he'd had and he's like
he's like and you don't really think
about it like when you move into a place
like what the neighbors are like but
it's like those people are gonna affect
your life like to a very large degree
and it's something that's almost kind of
like an afterthought and he's like maybe
it shouldn't be and so he's like so i
was wondering why there wasn't that much
horror about you know horrible neighbors
like or
in this case like really [ __ ]
satanic [ __ ] neighbor neighbors i
mean just they're the [ __ ] worst it's
just
it's it's just unimaginably bad like
what these uh what these two old folks
get up to
but yeah so uh definitely if you have
kindle unlimited and you like folk
horror uh and you like stuff that's
really really like gorgeous and
descriptive and i mean his writing style
is just really really
it's really beautiful it's just very
very literary and very poetic a little
bit in a way um especially the way he
describes
describes various uh things describes
the setting but yeah it's just i had a
really really good time with this it's
really [ __ ] up and it was one of those
ones too where i don't know if this is
just because uh because i'm getting
soft-hearted in my old age or something
like that but sometimes like you knew
something bad was gonna happen and it's
just like i just kind of felt like my
stomach like clutch clutching like that
going oh [ __ ] i know this was i know
where this is going and i don't know
where i want if i want to keep reading
it or not but that's good though i mean
that means that that he did his job
because it's a horror novel and uh yeah
it's pretty horrific so yeah if you have
kindle unlimited definitely check it out
it's really really good and yeah i'll
definitely be doing more adam neville he
also wrote one called the reddening
which a lot of people like any one
called the ritual
uh so i'll probably be getting around to
those eventually as well but yeah so
this one's called cunning folk
so check it out and if you have read it
let me know what you think about it in
the comments and that will do it for
this tomes of terror i will see you guys
on the next one bye